I'm sorry I'm not there at the moment
I'm very busy however many happy returns
I'm gonna be with you again very soon
hey youtubers this Charlie who luck week
continues with my breakdown of how I
think Sherlock survived the fall at the
end of Reichenbach I know I totally
promised this to you guys yesterday but
I had to postpone it for all that Doctor
Who stuff that went on something about a
Christmas special a new doctor you know
if you're just finding me for the first
time I'm doing a special week of Doctor
Who and Sherlock programming I'm just
calling it who like week just in honor
of the Christmas special and Series
three coming back normally there's a
much more diverse offering a video but
special events demand special videos be
sure to subscribe to get everything
now let's get started so for the
purposes of this breakdown I'm assuming
the most logical course of events given
what we know already number one the
ingredients that are needed include one
Molly Hooper an undocumented cadaver a
squash ball a network of homeless spies
and a well thought out flight path from
the roof to the pavement to this
explanation assumes that it was in fact
Sherlock himself that went over the roof
and not the cadaver three starting from
the beginning Sherlock goes to Molly
tells her she matters and that she does
in fact account it's a double meaning
Molly likes to count things but Sherlock
finds one extra cadaver in the morgue
Molly miscounted for Sherlock falls from
the roof in such a way as to do the
least amount of physical damage to
himself he is injured enough to make it
believable to any passerby that he is
dead five Watson's vision is obscured by
a well-timed laundry truck
and is knocked to the ground by one of
Sherlock's homeless spies on a bicycle
Watson never sees Sherlock hit the
ground six Sherlock uses the squash ball
to stop the flow of blood to the point
where Watson takes his pulse Watson not
feeling a pulse and in the state of
shock believe Sherlock is dead but the
body still needs to be examined by the
morgue seven this is where Molly comes
back Sherlock is taken to the morgue
still appearing to be dead and is then
revived by Molly wherein they switch his
body with that of the cadaver they also
alter the records so that any official
investigating will find nothing out of
the ordinary ate the cadaver is buried
in Sherlock's grave nine supporting
evidence what makes this so plausible
answer Irene
remember Irene did the exact same thing
in scandal even Sherlock believed that
she was really dead loving to solve
puzzles she probably would have
explained how she did it much to his
delight when he saved her 10 Mycroft
where is Mycroft in all this he's
jokingly referred to as the British
government he knew all about Moriarty
long before Sherlock did and based on
that it's likely that he knows what
Sherlock is doing and is merely impeding
any further investigation into the
matter which is probably one of the
reasons Anderson lost his job obsessing
over it as we learned during the mini
episode 11
why is Sherlock doing this answer
Moriarty had threatened the lives of all
of Sherlock's closest friends Molly not
included interestingly enough even
though she was rather tied up with
Moriarty at one point if Sherlock didn't
make Moriarty's henchmen believe that he
was dead they would still have gone
after his friends 12 alternative
theories there are some who believe that
the laundry truck cushioned Sherlock's
fall but both Steven Moffat and Mark
Gatiss have said that the truck has
nothing to do with it all of the other
best theories have a lot of things in
common they all involve Molly and
Sherlock swapping the cadaver as well as
Sherlock jumping off the roof it's
really just the point of impact and the
body on the ground that our points of
contention but since there's so much fun
to speculate let me know what your best
theory is in the comments below or your
favorite theory that you may have seen
don't forget I'm also picking a random
subscriber to give a $20 Amazon gift
card to just randomly from the comments
all you have to do is comment I'm
working on a bunch more videos between
now and the premiere on January 1st be
sure to subscribe to get everything
right now you can click here to get my
breakdown of the mini episode and you
can click here to get my top ten moments
on Sherlock so far thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you